ich jetzt gerade so merke dass so viele
Leute krank werden denk ich so ey warum
nimmst du einfach nicht schwarzkümelöl
das ist für mich so warum nimmst du das
nicht einfach ich habe seit 5 Jahren
keine Probleme mehr mit irgendeiner
Erkältung so sonst war ich wirklich
jeden Winter mindestens einmal krank so
dass ich wirklich F Tage lang komplett
flach lag also ich bin jetzt auch
selbständig ich kann jetzt nicht einfach
ein Krankenschein nehmen und sagen so
ich komme jetzt einfach 5 Tage nicht ich
nehme wirklich seit 5 Jahren
Schwarzkümmelöl guck mal Flasche ist
schon wieder fast leer ihr müsst euch
halt vorstellen im Schwarzkümmelöl sind
so viele Vitamine drin Mineral Stoffe so
viel Gutes für euren Körper dass es
einfach grundsätzlich schon euer
Immunsystem stärken kann und bei mir ist
es definitiv der Fall ich habe euch ja
erzählt schildrüsen Unterfunktion gehabt
habe ich gar keine Probleme mehr mit
brauchte immer ganz viel Schlaf also mir
geht's einfach so gut wie noch nie und
dann nehme ich mir habe ich hier schon
direkt die nächste weil ich kann nicht
ohne also selbst wenn ich mal ein paar
Tage weg bin es geht einfach nicht mehr
ohne und das war's und so kommt ihr gut
durch den Winter also ich zumindest und
wenn ihr Fragen habt dann stellt sie
gerne unter dieses Video